c'est un faux dur emmanuel macron c'est
un vrai dur je pense je pense qu'il est
beaucoup plus dur que d'autres je pense
qu'il a peut-être plus d'intelligence
des situations là où hollande était un
vrai mou ou sarkozy était un faux dur je
pense que c'est tellement il s'excuse et
ses allures d'ange l'eau accompagné de
brigitte macron dans les sommets
internationaux et bien à la bo a besoin
de justement de se faire respecter de
faire entendre sa parole il est assez
dur
la façon dont il a traité l'histoire des
travail des tâches et moi je trouve que
c'était un exemple assez intéressant il
a échoué sur les routiers parce que
finalement les polonais ont fini par
dire oui à ce que demandait à ce que
demande et emmanuel macron sauf sur les
routiers
c'est un peu normal parce que le
chauffeur routier polonais il arrive à
la frontière voilà il va pas descendre
du camion à nos pratiques ce qui peut
pas remplacer aussitôt répondu je
répondrais deux choses assez un vrai dur
mais qui peut aussi essuyé des échecs et
peut-être qu'il va essuyer un échec
en tous les cas c'est le souhait le plus
cher de monsieur mélenchon le bouffon du
roi où son bouffon à lui d'air
et la deuxième chose qu'il faut
souligner c'est que ce mouvement des
routiers
ils ne m'ont avis il n'est pas très
dangereux tant que les petits patrons ne
sont pas rentrés dans la danse parce que
le problème de cette profession c'est
justement tout ces petits patrons qui
ont bien du mal à joindre les deux bouts
qui ont deux ou trois chauffeurs qui
sont chauffeurs eux mêmes c'est des
vrais tpe qui sont concernés d'ailleurs
par la réforme du code du travail
et si eux entrent dans la danse parce
qu'ils appartiennent pas la cgt ou fo
refuse apprécie plutôt l'assouplissement
à la normale en même temps